hello everyone and welcome to the final
match of the 2019 Fida grand prix its
young Nepal nation versus Alexander
Greece shook and they've already played
to classical games both classical games
were drawn and they already played one
rapid game the one where Greece had the
white pieces and nipple had the black
pieces that one was also drawn so now
this is the second game of the rapid if
this is also drawn then they are going
into into more rapid the ten minutes
once these are the 25 minutes plus nine
seconds increments increment Rapids and
then of course into blitz end into
Armageddon
so it's English of best interest to
either win this with the black pieces or
or draw the game so he can go into more
rapids with the white pieces but that
being said we do have a few nice photos
again compliments of Nikki Riga so let's
check them out here we have a very nice
photo Grisha just arriving shaking hands
there you have it but it's from the one
where you've had the white pieces but
also from the rapids so let's just check
that out for a few seconds also we have
a very nice close-up of Alexander Grigio
there you have it and/or he has nice
color as you know it's a really intense
game and also a very nice close-up of
nipple there we have it so I do hope you
enjoyed that now let's check out the
game
Napo has the white pieces and he opened
with e4 we have E 5 not sorry not East 6
no not the French sorry about that
we have 9 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and now Bishop to c4 so the Italian game
is on the board and here Knight to f6
and now nice the g5 is a very nice move
but it was not played in this game here
we have d3 so the joke of piano is on
the board Bishop to c5 and now C 3 we
have d6 by black now comes a for pushing
on the queenside preparing a 5 and B 4
and here just a 6 making some room for
the bishop on a 7 with h3 by neppo also
taking away the g4 Square from the night
and from the bishop bishop back to a 7
and here there are a few games worship
the g5 was played in this position a 5
is a known move in this position but
after castles which never plays we have
a complete
new game on their hands since move eight
so a six bug does the same taking away
the g5 square from whites night and dark
square Bishop rook to e1 and now comes
castles by Grisha
we have Knight B to d2 and this Knight
is now of course as is usual in the
indie Italian game is either coming to
c4 after the bishop moves or you can go
nice to f1 and from there to III or or
g3 depending on on what black plays rook
to e8 by black at some point black wants
to push d5 so you wanted the e5 phone as
protected as as much as possible and
finally before grabbing that expansion
on the Queen side Bishop to e6 Bishop
captures on e6 and now rook captures on
e6 the problem with F captors on e6 is
that yes it does help you execute d5 but
after this night comes here the e5 pawn
will be weak as it will be attacked by
both nights so you want to play rook
captures on e6 so the rook now also will
be protecting d5 pawn after d5 is pushed
weave Queen to c2 by Nampo developing
the Queen Queen to d7 angry should also
prepares to bring the other look into
the game with Knight to c4 and now
finally d5 so now you can see that both
Knight and rook are nicely defending the
e5 pawn we have each chapters on d5
Queen Kat for some d5 and now Knight
back to e3 attacking the Queen Queen
back to the 7 and now Knight back to c4
here Napo is test English together to
see if he should be interested in
playing something else but like we
already mentioned GUI should be
satisfied with the draw so he simply
repeats we have Queen to d5 therefore
again repeats nice to e3 Queen back to
b7 and here neppo is not interested in a
draw he does have the white pieces and
it's only move 18 so it would be it
would be you know pretty much a crime
against chess to go for a draw here with
the white pieces so he pushes a b5 and
okay Knights the a5 and now c4 so it's
not much but it is a small victory for
the moments the a5 night is out of the
game with Bush up to d4 attacking the
rook rook the b1 and now a capture some
b5 a capture some d5 and rook goes back
to eh and here C 5 by nipple
so here you have to decide do you wanna
capture on III with Bishop captures
Bishop characters and then go Queen d5
as you've removed the defender of the d5
square but then white can go look before
you can go Roque one and and never will
try would never will continue playing on
the Queen sides trying to take advantage
of the weird position of the knight on a
five but after c5 girl issue goes Knight
to d5 he goes for a different line
Knight captures on d5 Queen captures on
d5 Knight captures on d4 now and here
it's best to capture with the Queen
after Queen captures nipple would most
likely go for rook to e4 pull the Queen
back and then go Bishop III and continue
the game with you know being being
slightly better but here Grisha played
pawn captures on Eve on d4 and this
allows nipple a lot of activity so here
never played rook captures any it with
check rook captures any eight and now
comes well just just a very nice move
even feel free to pause the video and
try to find this very sneaky move by
nipple I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
the move is Bishop to f4 attacking the
c7 pawn and now you will see that it's
not all that easy to defend this pawn
one nice example is for example if Queen
d7 just at defending the c7 pundants e6
comes and now if B captures on c6 Bishop
back to d2 traps the night and it's a
very very unfortunate to lose your night
this way now if you go here just pawn
captures and the Queen and Knight are
under attack you're gonna lose the night
here and if you don't do this for
example if you try something like rook
to e2 doesn't really work yes you do pin
the bishop but Queen d1 now attacks the
rook and also the bishop still attacks
the night so here you will lose the
night or you will have to give up the
exchange here so not something you want
to do and also if you just defend the
night with the rook then a double attack
will will get the job done so after this
Bishop to e4
good hook finds a nice way to defend it
we have looked at east 7 but now Quinta
a4 just attacking the knight with the
Queen so
how do you defend here Trisha guitar of
b6 defending tonight and also freeing
the b7 square for this night to get into
the game but of course nepo is not about
to allow that we have c6 taking the b7
square away from the night and still the
night is stuck there you can get back
into the game we have kink the h7 by
Grisha preparing to expand here on the
on the King side and the king will be
somewhat safer on h7 but now comes look
the before and this is what it was all
about force this night to remain trapped
on a5 and go after the d4 pawn there's
no way black and defend the d4 pawn now
we have Queen to e6 and now just rook
captures on d4 with f5 by Griff cook and
now Bishop to e3 blocking the e-file
that the Queen and rook occupy and now
g5 Grisha has no time to wait here he's
down upon he has a funny knight on e5
that's really not gonna see any any
light of day anytime soon so he has to
start attacking here and here
Queen to b4 a very nice idea that
prevents f4 because now if f4 rookie for
will simply win that rook on e7 so it's
not not not an option so after Queen
before we have looked to g7 getting the
rock out of the way and now comes looked
at d8 and here finally after the Queen
is guarding the B 3 square where Gary
tries to activate the night with Knights
the b3 and now rook to d7 is a very nice
move as the Queen will be too busy busy
guarding both the d7 point and the night
on be three but the nepo finds a very
interesting line also Bishop to d4 here
Nepos idea is that okay if Knight
captures then the Queen will capture
back and only then I will never play
rook to d7
but here after this Knight to b3 and
Bishop to d4 guruship decided to go for
rook to e7
but this doesn't this doesn't really
work and here nipple nipple found a very
nice idea how to take advantage of this
if now rook to d7 it is possible if rook
to d7 and rook captures pawn captures
Queen captures and now yes you will be
able to capture on b3 but also Queen
captures and before is now possible and
you will go into this Queen and pollen
game that should be winning for white
but
has to try something but like I said
after look to a seven nepo found the
most cleanest way to end the game so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this well instant win for white
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you probably have read
the quote above the board and for those
who just won't enjoy show the correct
movies actually Queen captures on e7
with check and it was in this position
almost 36 that Alexander gray she
resigned to the game
what if you resigned well there is
nothing to do here
you are in check next move you're gonna
lose the Queen or you can grab whites
Queen but it doesn't help you after
Queen captures nepos idea was rook to be
7 now attack the Queen the Hindu Queen
cannot move as the King occupies the h7
square so here you would have to capture
and now there is no more preventing this
point from queening or on the other hand
even if you don't capture it rookie to
try something like Knight captures here
rook captures Queen with check so you
don't have time to grab the b5 pawn and
guard the c7 pawn after the King moves
you're gonna grab this pawn Knight
character son b5 sure but after the rook
moves this point is now queening even if
you try something like this the point
was still just Queen you can even give
up a rook the queen is coming into the
game and it is all over
so of course both of them notice and
after Queen captures on e7 it was in
this wonderful position that we should
resign the game and yan the pony she is
the 2019 Fida Grand Prix winner and he's
one step closer to her to the candidates
tournament and which is of course one
step closer to challenging Magnus
Carlsen for the title in the next
Watchers championship match sir and it's
very interesting if you if you think
about it Grichuk eliminated Hikaru
Nakamura
in the in the semi-finals but he
eliminated Nakamura in the classical
time format just winning the the game
where he had the white pieces where his
nipple really went through hell to
defeat tirado slob wait a sec drawing
both classical games then drawing both
rapid games then drawing the the quicker
rapid game determinant 1 where avatar
had two white pieces and then finally
nipple one the one
where he had the black pieces so it was
a very important win illuminating erotic
in the semifinals with the black pieces
so he was I believe much more prepared
for this final round as he had a lot
more practice against the weightage then
then we should head against Nakamura in
the semi-finals but yeah just a
beautiful line beautiful finish by Napo
and what a way to win a defeated Grand
Prix 2019 with with Queen captures on e7
just just beautiful it's it's not as
nice as Constance Queen captures on h6
his win over Kerrigan and in the last
game of the roaches championship match
but it is a very nice way to win any
tournament so that's the game and we
don't have one more photo also
compliment of Nikki Riga there you have
it this is the handshake a very nice
firm handshake there you can see the
position on the board after Queen
captures on e7 I agree should
immediately congratulated him and well
it was just just a beautiful moment yeah
like I said if you enjoyed the photos to
check out Nikki Regas workout put both
her Instagram and Twitter links in the
profile in the description below so do
check them out and also I would like to
thank Nicolas but our Gregory show of a
penguin Gary Silberman and Joseph was
said for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I will see you soon before the start
of OT box Norway championship we are
continuing the Capablanca saga and the
good news everyone I've just received
the word that Argan amount of chess
clock is coming to iOS very soon so not
only Android users will be able to use
it but also app Apple users so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and
yeah thank you and I will see you soon